*Triggered* What is this guys?!
*RAWRR*
"If we don't post any memes for a week, Pewdiepie will be forced to do original content"
(NANI?)
*This is what happened to the car roof slapping meme in case you were wondering* *RIP 399*
K.O.
HRRRRrrrRrr *grunting*
*GTA SA music plays*
You think I'm scared of you bi-  nine year olds?! *chuckles*
Let's review the memes (claps hands) LWIAY
🎵leave your entries in the subreddit bros🎵
🎵and I'll watch submissions🎵
🎵In the next episode of LWIAY🎵
Hmmm 🤔
WHAT IS THIS? Delete. this. now!
*nervous chuckle*
*skrattar*
I love this meme, it just keeps on living.
[ pewds laughs ]
I miss - I mi - You know what, I miss them. That's the weirdest thing.
That's right, I'm not afraid to tell people the world.
How did LP know a man's hands were purple
when he was wearing his color blind glasses?
*burp*
The reason why Pew News is the most underrated news source on the internet
It's in the wrong category
Wait it's in gaming? Are u kidding me SIVE?
(claps hands)
What are you doing? You put it as gaming?! Pew News is not a game. It's a serious- This is so embarrassing
*pewds cries in embarrassment*
Never getting a raise now
(Reads) Guys, I like the idea of not posting memes for a week
so Pewds will have to make original con-
Stahp it
Is this gonna be all of it now?
Memes about not making original content = memes
Which is giving me original content. Joke's on you DJT
He said: without you guys, I wouldn't be here. But little does he know: without him, most of us wouldn't be here
that is the mopiest
trash I have ever heard
What? Thanks to some youtuber? That's right. I indirectly gave birth to 64 million kids
(giggle)
Now that's a lot of s p e r m
(Reads) Hope Pewds sees this so he'll start playing it
Detroit: Become human
All right enough
"plAy tHE viDEoGaMe Pe-"
FINE. If this video -
If this video gets five
*eargasm*
hundred thousand likes, I will play Detroit: Become human
Just because this gameplay looks absolutely lit
Invent football
decide it's rules
invest millions of pounds
watch everyone play better than you
IT'S COMING HOME
No, it isn't you dummy country. Why am I here?
*giggle*
Why do I hate England?
*not serious*
Hit him with the silence. nine year olds.
start with on 20... spread awareness... 20?!
ohh so it's starting next week
Oh, so we could actually work.
Oh, no, I'm shaking guys.
I'm shaking. I'm so scared
You can't live without the memes. Just like I can't live without unoriginal content. We're in this together. Dammit
Stop pretending like you're better than me
when you see how big his headphone cable is.
That's right everybody
I would totally buy my razor headphones.
*video game SFX*
That's right. They got really-
what's great about these, that they got extremely long cables for the headphones
I can just walk anywhere
399 : Its incredible
and I'm just keep walking
I'm just gonna keep wa-
look how far away I AAAAAMMMM (Japan)
*door closes*
They're also 399, which is a great price. Thank you guys.
Who said girth was important? No one
iPewdy
Oh, I've seen this
guys
someone made the iCarly intro
*laughs*
🎵I know🎵
🎵You see 🎵
🎵Somehow the world will change for me 🎵
🎵And be so wonderful 🎵
👏 👏👏👏
*pewds enjoying every second*
🎵Live life, breathe air 🎵
Ahh *slurp*
🎵 it's all for real 🎵
*brad makes cameo*
Brad and Brad 2
🎵I'm telling you just 🎵
*audio glitch*
A lot of people don't seem to understand that
Sive is actually a person
so I'm just gonna clarify now
Sive is Brad 2
Here he is, hello everybody
*an imaginary audience claps*
Give a round of applause
He's done a great job. He doesn't deserve to be called just Brad 2
Okay now its over
Let's move on Brad 2. BACK TO WORK.
A+ FAHEDO27
*coughs*
I got G fuel in my lungs
Dad why is my sister named Rose?
Because your mother likes roses.
Thanks dad. No problem
The idea of not posting memes for a week. So Pewds will have to make original content.
Oh, I'm sorry
lol liking the idea of not posting memes for a week
But then using the idea's meme to make a meme which in contradicts to your liking. This is memeception.
Wow, this is this is truly W O K E
I am impressed.
woaw that is really creepy and weird.
What the actual - ?
it's cool, but oh
*bleh meme*
Yucky yucky ew
You laugh
You LOSS
*pewds skrattar*
Good one. Good one
when you tell a slightly offensive joke in a video
pewds
subscribers *nine year olds*
newcomers
news media
accurate. well done.
an accurate meme 👏👏
*senpai appreciates*
Looking for LWIAY content
Guys i like the idea of not posting memes for a week so pewds will have to make a
shtop it!
What is this meta meme? It's so weird.
I just made a new meme
I hope the bros like it
Guys, i like the
*laugh censored by black screen*
I'm not posting memes for a week. So pewds will I have to make original content
the meta meme of this is off the charts, man.
Fortnite players petition to add ability to thank the bus driver before jumping
Why can't you do that? So disrespectful
I don't understand why anyone plays this game.
*mimics baby* B... B...
*mom* He's about to say his first word!
babypie : BUT AM I GONNA
I get it. That was clever.
Please Felix, can you have Marzia co-host meme review, pew news, or lwiay just for one episode-
You guys really want to get rid of me, don't you?
Its so nice to have an audience that
doesn't turn against you and want other people to appear on my channel desperately
It's very nice I love- I love this. This is great. All right, you've been doing this 7 years now. [wait then how can the subs be all 9yos? *hmmmm*]
Can someone else, can someone else take over please?
*first few seconds of pew news intro plays*
Good evening. I'm Erin Burnett.
And I'm the new host of pew news
first story
Where is Poppy Harlow?
some suspect she traveled forward through time to stop this 👇 from happening
*Brad in Deji mode*
Suck your mum
suck your mum
succ your mum
*pew news intro*
Most ambitious projects ever
Kalifa tower 2009
Mars exploration program 2012
PewDiePie's subreddit 2018 : guys, I like the idea of not posting memes for one week so pewds will have to make original content
let's start this with 20 - 27th (July)
spread awareness by posting this until then
let's spread the awareness everyone
Let's make sure everyone gets this message that I like the idea of not posting memes for a week
so pewds will have to
FINE
you think i can't do it?
if this is a challenge
I won't do LWIAY next week
I don't need this.
I gotta make a bridge out of my sound waves
*laughs*
*laugh intensifies*
Felix Kjellberg announces Bridge 2 👏
it's gonna be great
🎵whaaadaaa
f***🎵
Used to be simpler times, you just say whatever you wanted
by order of the nine-year-old army
we will not post memes starting the 20th - 27th so you will have to make original content
are you threatening me, nine year-old army?
the subreddit will decide your fate
pewdie : I am the subreddit
not yet
pewdie : Its treason then
pewdie :  make fun of little kids week 2
👏
YAAAAAAAAS
*jingle*
Don't think I won't do it
I'm looking at you little children 👀
We need to collect all the promises he made
I will that's so cute
*coy laugh* no please no
i'm like the worst youtuber ever. I say doesn't gonna do so much.
I need to stop making pro-
I want to. Its cute.
Where do I get paper from? I don't know where you get paper
crazy. you guys are crazy.
You guys are asking for way too much in me.
Okay. I'm already looking at funny pictures.
It's hard enough here, okay?
Longest things on earth
The Great Wall
The Nile
The Qingdao Haiwan Bridge
The cable of these headphones
*thinks for a bit*
I wanna see how much do they actually cost
*headphone users, brace for impact*
99 99
That's a great price
XXXTENTACION donated
$15
Did he really? That'd be so sick.
I dont think he did.
Either way
Rest in peace, XXX
r/PewDiePie submissions :
Guys, I like the idea of not posting memes for one week
pewds
*pewds loses it, seeing Dr Phil*
Yeah, honestly I want to do more Dr. Phil
but I feel like it's too far.
some, some of them are just deranged children
and I'm literally just making fun of them.
It was fun for a while
But if I make it a thing, I'll just look like a an idiot
pewdie : c'mon mayn. come awn come awn
*echo*
c'mon you can DOOO
This is what it's like living in the same houses
pewdie : AWH *underwater sounds*
Marziqueen : and this is a full size so you get tons of product
The first time I try this I instantly thought
*pewdie howls in background*
that it smelled like summer
*howling intensifies*
and it must be the kelp, obviously
*pewdie = kaiju shrieking sounds*
But it's just not so refreshing
pewdie : OMG, Jesus Christ!
👏👏
*meme finesse*
Good meme Dr_Sandvich
(reads) Its official. We are the dumbest civilization ever.
People are donating money to Kylie Jenner to help her become the world's youngest female billionaire
Oh, yeah, cuz she's evaluated to like 900 million or something
to help her become the world's youngest female billionaire
How how does she have so much? I don't get it
Girlfriend
No girlfriend
Marzia
I'm not saying this is true,
But look inside my wallet
No ooo
*cute cringy whimper*
*gasping for air*
*inaudible* (sorry, guys)
I think i need to do a meme review on this meme. I think it's time for it to go.
I think it's time for it to just go  a w a y
eugh, I love how it doesn't need anything. It's just
*pewdi-hiss*
It's like then you lost me, you know.
OH
EWW
AEW
I read a comment :
Where's her left hand?!
hmmm 🤔
mazie!
PewDiePie after thanking the bus driver.
Jeez
yeah
This man slaps your bus drivers ass
What do you do?
*funny*
Guys, I like the idea of not posting ..
*overwhelmed*
AH
So confused. Why is this a meme?
Nurse : sir, you've been in a coma, since 2013. This is year 2018.
Me : Oh boy, I can't wait to see my favorite youtuber  ƿ૯ωძɿ૯ƿɿ૯ playing video games...
FINE I'M GONNA PLAY IT
All right, I'll play beyond or whatever-its-called (Detroit)
It's called such a dumb name
Elon Musk presents how the Hyperloop will be designed
Yeuh, that's cool
That's it for this week's of LWIAY
and next weeks as well. That's R I G H T 😭
Thank you guys though for watching this video, leaving a like
hit subscribe if you're not already and submit a meme in the PewDiePie subreddit
Join the community. Have some fun.
and I'll see you guys NOT next week.
BYE
No brofist for you
*pewds, my life is a lwiay 😭*
Forget about it.
I know you're just here for the A S S outro anyway
*A S S outro plays*
*always the same level*
*all this hardwork to defeat a bone dino*
*bye guys <3*